tu es un homme intéressant Ecosse
tu es un Avenger
tu as une fille mais tu as perdu
beaucoup de temps comme moi qui
es-tu je suis l'homme qui peut te donner
plus de temps
oui mon Dieu tu ne peux pas lui faire confiance je c'est juste que je
juste dans la mesure où il peut nous donner une seconde
chance,
il m'apportera ce dont j'ai besoin ou
tout ce que vous appelez une vie prendra fin,
vous ne voudrez peut-être pas qu'elle regarde ça, nous
avions un accord, nous pensions que vous
pourriez gagner, je n'ai pas besoin de
gagner, nous  les deux doivent juste perdre
désolé Cassie Ant-Man et WASP
Quantumania prêts PG-13 dans les salles le
17 février devinez quoi Les billets pour les fans de Marvel
sont officiellement en vente pour
Marvel Studios Ant-Man et WASP
Quantum Mania Scotland
un homme qui peut vous donner le  une chose que tu
veux, quel est ce
moment qui
m'apportera ce dont j'ai besoin ou tout ce que
tu appelles une vie prendra fin
[Musique]